on est au 4 rue basse froid dans le 11e
arrondissement de paris et du coup je
vous parle de l'oeuvre de caching qui
est là
[Musique]
c'est une artiste militante en fait et
elle fait des peintures qui célèbre un
peu la diversité de l'humanité
du coup elle s'interroge sur l'identité
sur les normes sociales et notamment en
peignant des personnages qui sont non
genre et on a un exemple d'une tête d'un
personnage qui apparaît plutôt comme
masculin notamment à cause des
moustaches
mais en fait tous ces personnages sont à
moitié masculin à moitié féminin
[Musique]
l'origine du projet est à la croisée de
nos de nos intérêts en même temps de nos
intérêts scolaire pour l'histoire de
l'art et le patrimoine et matrimoine
donc et aussi de nos convictions
féministes et de notre sensibilité les
femmes artistes étaient très souvent
oubliés ou on n'en parlait pas trop
alors qu'elle existe et donc certes
elles sont quand même moins nombreuses
que les hommes
artiste parce qu'elles ont eu plus de
mal à se former au 19e siècle où etc
mais elles existent elles sont là et
c'est ce qu'on veut vraiment montrer
avec la cartographie on est au un
passage roche dans le xième à paris et
on est devant une oeuvre en mosaïque de
léonore yéti qui a été fait en 1990
alors ce qui est intéressant c'est que
là il nous reste seulement le rhinocéros
mais avant il y avait huit animaux qui a
été représentée au dessus de chacune des
petites fenêtres grillagées donc
l'ensemble de l'oeuvre s'appelait le zoo
et ça crée une grande ménagerie ça
permet aussi de voir comment certaines
oeuvres de femmes en fait
malheureusement sont perdus effacés
[Musique]
le patrimoine il se construit pas
seulement par des artistes il se
construit aussi par des par des gens qui
financent la culture et qui valorise la
culture donc il ya par exemple la
galerie des femmes qui a été créée par
antoinette fouque que c'était pas une
artiste mais elle a permis de valoriser
beaucoup beaucoup de femmes ça s'adresse
à tout le monde
c'est une carte qu'on a voulu simple
d'utilisation et avec des notices qui
sont rédigées très simplement il ya une
vocation pédagogique
il ya une vocation aussi à faire
redécouvrir la ville a invité les gens à
se balader
dans paris découvrir des oeuvres qu'ils
ne connaissaient pas à côté de chez eux
[Musique]
les oeuvres qui sont présentes sur la
carte sont elles sont assez récentes en
fait elle se bat pas plus et pas plus
ancien que le 19e siècle
on peut penser à la citation de virginia
woolf le plus souvent dans l'histoire
anonyme était une femme
et du coup c'est ce qu'elle sait ce
qu'elle montre qu'en fait les femmes ont
été de tout temps en visibiliser et
quand elle crée quelque chose on ne
disait pas que c'était leur oeuvre à l
on disait anonymes ou alors on dit on
parlait d'un homme de leur entourage
pour parler de cette oeuvre l'a donc par
exemple c'est la femme de dentelle qui a
fait cette oeuvre là où la fille d'un
tel etc
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est un projet qui va évoluer qui va
être complétée au fur et à mesure
notamment grâce aux collaborations des
visiteurs en fait on a une page de
contact sur le site qui permet d'envoyer
si vous connaissez une oeuvre dans la
ville où que vous avez entendu parler
d'une artiste de nous l'envoyer et après
des recherches on la mettra sur la carte